AI is a tool in the Armory of two
superpowers it's probably best to think
of a cold war framework and to see this
as the latest
feature of the arms race that
characterizes cold Wars
[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters of
me Winston Marshall at The Spectator in
London today I'm joined by esteemed
historian Neil Ferguson author of the
books Empire how Britain made the modern
world Colossus the rise and fall of the
American Empire and most recently doomed
the politics of catastrophe uh Neil's
also a senior fellow at the Hoover
Institute and the senior fellow at the
Belfast Center for Science and
international Affairs at Harvard
University and with bloomberg.com he
published his piece the aliens have
landed and we created them which is the
topic of our conversation today Neil
thank you so much for speaking with me
it's a pleasure to be with you Winston
so I want to get into AI as as I said
you've published this piece with
bloomberg.com the subtitle is the
Cassandra's are out in force claiming
artificial intelligence will be the end
of mankind they have a very good point
and this is in response to elieza
yatkowski's piece for Time Magazine
which was falling off the back of the
petition signed by various though not
all people in the uh AI industry if it's
an industry
um calling for a six-month moratorium
halting the development of AI so before
getting into your piece I wondered if
you might tell me why you're interested
in AI just to set a bit of a background
into you coming into writing uh the the
the piece well Doom my most recent book
has a section uh towards the end in
which I ask about the various ways in
which we as a species can be offed and
although people talk a lot about climate
change that doesn't seem to me like the
most efficient way of getting rid of
humanity uh nuclear war would do a
better job much faster and then of
course the question becomes what other
technological innovations might lead to
the destruction of homo sapiens now I
came across Elisa yudkovsky's work when
I was researching doom and he was one of
those people who suggested that there
was a non-trivial risk that artificial
general intelligence if you could create
that
would go after us this is the kind of
Skynet scenario from the Terminator
movies I'm not entirely a subscriber to
that view I I have a somewhat different
take on the threat posed by large
language models and that's what the
piece really does it doesn't go with
yodkovsky all the way to they're out to
kill us my argument is that if you think
about the potential applications of
large language models in politics
these will be an even more potent tool
for polarization and the spreading of
disinformation than social networks and
social media were back in 2016. and so
we should be very uneasy about the speed
with which large language models are
being rolled out are so near to a U.S
election and I I was very struck as I
did my homework for the piece by the
fact that the proponents of more or less
unrestrained developments of artificial
intelligence like my old friend Reid
Hoffman
don't really seem to address that issue
and and they should because after all
it's pretty much the same people that
gave you uh the social networks online
and I don't think any of them could
really claim today that that didn't have
a major political downside so I do
wonder why we're not discussing much
more
urgently the potential use of AI in
American politics that that I actually
have is the aspect I understand because
I'd like to put a pin in your cow skin
and the real because he says it's the
end of humanity yeah I mean he says
essentially if you create an
intelligence that's Superior to human
intelligence it will wipe us out and
it's a bit like I don't know if you've
read uh Lucy Shin's uh book The Dark
Forest which is the sequel to The Three
body problem but in that he argues that
if there's any Superior intelligence in
the universe
it will if it discovers us it will
immediately eradicate us just in case we
might eradicate it and that dark Forest
theory is kind of what yodkowsky is
saying that's why the headline was you
know the aliens are here and we created
them if you think of artificial
intelligence as non-human intelligence
which would be a much better thing to
call it I think artificial intelligence
sounds a little bit harmless but if you
called it non-human or inhuman
intelligence then you'd recognize that
you're creating aliens within and I
think the yukovsky argument is if you
create an intelligence Superior to ours
we should expect to be eradicated I
don't think that's right
because there's a jump in faith that he
assumes that they they then would act on
their own accord which which I I that
that jump in the Doom says I don't see
how AI can suddenly decide to act I can
see and it's like the at this point it's
a cliche that pay-per-clip maximizer
idea where you give it one task and into
are doing it it wipes out Humanity in
the meantime by mistake by mistake and
in your article you talk about
maybe climate change being an example of
that how do we do of climate change okay
the AI decides let's get rid of humanity
I there's a big jump there which doesn't
quite add up add up for me and and I
haven't followed yukowski entirely and
so in fact he is there's a interview
he's done recently of Lex Friedman
earlier this year he's he borderline
breaks down into he's on the verge of
tears he is so certain this is the end
of humanity but you you do so you don't
agree that it is no I don't and I don't
think it's
um I don't think it's convincing that
that would automatically follow the Dark
Forest Theory applies to human created
artificial intelligence systems my point
is that these are incredibly powerful
tools that can be used uh to cause even
more pandemonium in our societies than
social media uh have caused so far but
there's another point
I read on on my way here a headline uh
U.S legislators say AI should not be put
in control of nuclear weapons and that
gets to the heart of a really important
point about uh about AI in its uh
potential military applications
if you read the book that Eric Schmidt
did with Henry Kissinger on AI one of
the most striking passages is about the
way uh an artificial intelligence would
approach Warfare
and it would approach it in a different
way from uh humans just in the same way
that it approaches chess in a different
way from humans with likely very
non-human decisions if if you Empower AI
to make Battlefield decisions in fact to
give it the trigger then that would be
highly dangerous now it's reassuring to
hear that American legislators don't
want this to happen and I think there is
already some kind of self-denying
ordinance at the Pentagon not to have uh
unintermediated AI decision making I.E
the kill switch will still be in human
hands but there's no International
Convention to that effect and there's
nothing to stop say China from having AI
enabled weapon systems making far more
rapid decisions about targeting and
attacking than our systems so we have a
major problem when you think about the
military applications in effect
private sector actors are developing the
next generation of of weapons
in marked contrast to say mid-20th
Century uh innovation in which the
Manhattan Project was a was a government
Enterprise
it's a little bit as if nuclear weapons
were being invented by uh our Boeing and
and General Motors in the mid 20th
century rather than by the US government
there's an arms race at the moment in
large language models and other AI but
it's not so much between the US and
China it's really between a handful of
companies of which Google and Microsoft
are probably the furthest out there but
Amazon and Facebook can't be entirely
out of this to say nothing of Apple
meanwhile in China we've got a couple of
companies maybe three that can do this
have the compute power to do it that
arms race is going to produce with a
very high probability unintended
consequences not only in the military
domain but also in the domain of Medical
Science AI is hugely powerful for
medical scientific research that's clear
look at Alpha fold one of deepmind's
greatest achievements to date maybe Demi
sassibus's greatest achievement but
there are other ways in which AI in the
realm of of Biotech could be very
dangerous indeed biological weapons and
chemical weapons were outlawed by
conventions reached in the 20th century
but how are we to say if those
conventions will be adhered to the
Soviet Union didn't in fact adhere to
them so I worry a lot about how AI can
not only control potentially control
weapon systems including nuclear weapon
systems but also how AI can become
involved in a new era of biological
warfare research that would be really
dangerous putting on your sci-fi hack
could you
kind of give an example of how you think
that AI will affect geopolitics like
play that out a little bit well I don't
think you need to to do sci-fi I mean I
I am as readers of Doom will know a
believer that one should read science
fiction and that it's very difficult as
an historian to think about the future
without some science fiction in your
head because ultimately history will
tell you a lot because the nature of
power doesn't change but it won't really
give you a clue about the unintended and
intended consequences of technological
innovation and science fiction is quite
good at making you alive to that I'm a
big devotee not only of Lucy Shin but of
Neil Stevenson whose books everyone
should know everyone should have read
snow crash and kryptonomicon these are
extremely important books
so I don't think one needs to be as good
as Lucy shin and Neil Stevenson to do
this I think you just need to ask
yourself what are the lessons of the war
in Ukraine
the lesson of the war in Ukraine is that
very accurate targeting and precision
Weaponry mean very high casualties in
Conflict that's the distinguishing
feature of this war the really high
percentages of both sides that get
killed and that's all to do with
targeting and and the accuracy of the
weapons so it's not difficult to see
that you could simply take an AI and
Empower it to make those decisions and
it would do it faster than humans it's
quite a slow process even with the
technology that that the ukrainians have
at their disposal to collate all the
information and you'll get information
from multiple sources which is
essentially adding up to a spatial uh
identification of where Russian forces
are Russian assets are and then you
decide to to hit them well AI can
definitely do that faster than humans
but do you want war to be waged at that
Tempo that would be my question because
it clearly would be even more
destructive and really really hard to
stop it would be War at an unprecedented
speed with the obvious risk of
escalation that I think would certainly
be present in the case of a war over
Taiwan I mean there are limits on the
escalation that can happen I think in
the case of the war in Ukraine
it's a little less obvious what the
limits are in the case of a U.S China
war over Taiwan so I don't think that's
science fiction I think that's very much
in the present day and within the reach
of the existing Technologies so so back
to the petition then if uh assuming then
that other these other geopolitical
forces other nations are all thinking
about AI just as much as the Western
nations are and they aren't going to put
a halt to development of AI what is the
point in this petition to stop it and
can it really have an effect do you
really think there'll be a moratorium on
it I don't uh think there will be I
think if I were not at open AI I would
probably if I were at an arrival company
trying to develop AI particularly if I
wanted it to be of commercial value I'd
really want a moratorium on on open AI
because open AI is kind of suddenly
ahead of the field it's because of the
large language model because I think
they just let chat GPT loose and took
everybody by surprise by doing that and
and so I think a lot of the argument
that's going on for a moratorium is
really just the other tech companies
saying can we catch up so I don't take
that too seriously not nor even if it
were entirely altruistic do I think it's
likely that a bunch of private sector
actors will reach some kind of a
moratorium the only actors that can do
this are governments now we know
governments can uh agree to freeze
particular Technologies because
biological weapons were outlawed by a
convention
that went into Force when Richard Nixon
was president and I I think that was
important although we know the Soviets
cheated it was far from easy for for
them to produce covertly biological
weapons we want to make it difficult to
produce uh
uh AI systems that are lethal to humans
that seems obvious uh I don't really uh
see a reason why we aren't negotiating
an International Convention
to limit their use in war right now and
I think the U.S and China in particular
need to be talking about that because
it's certainly not going to be figured
out by Elon uh on the phone to Samuel
this sort of goes back now to a point
you made earlier in the in the
conversation which is the most pressing
which I which I think I agree with you
is the most pressing concern about Ai
and AGI or AI is the llms and the uh and
chat gbt and and how it might affect
um let's say an election as it's coming
up and I had a little toy around with uh
chat gbt and it turns out it did not it
didn't mind questions uh uh pertinent
questions about Jesus Christ but it did
not like pertinent questions about the
prophet Muhammad nor about his
um youngest wife and uh so I it was my
experience uh and uh and users can can
have a go themselves but uh that it's
it's already internalized uh Islamic
blasphemy laws
um and
um there's I've also seen uh examples of
how it's treating Trump differently from
Biden uh do you I mean it's sort of
Unstoppable at this point how chap gbt
uh could influence an election and and
my experience is that this isn't this
this is there's humans forces behind it
that that it would allow me to to
question uh question Jesus Christ but
not the prophet Muhammad that's not
happening there that's a human that's
that's behind it that's affecting it so
so are we gonna have a a similar issue
of humans behind in open let's say at
the company open AI like we had at
Twitter uh of trying to manipulate
things and we saw the Twitter files is
that a series concern is anything that
can be done about that well you're not
the only person to run these experiments
to see if uh it has a political agenda
quite a lot of people have and it's
clear that that chat GPT is about as
woke as Silicon Valley is generally I
don't think that's too surprising if you
remember a few years back Microsoft uh
tried out a chat bot the name of which
now escapes me but this was uh eight or
so years ago and because they hadn't
built in any uh of those uh controls it
very quickly started to spout uh wild
and sometimes uh right wing as well as
downright obscene language and so they
clearly didn't want that to happen again
so what do you do well you you you
create some kind of filters to make sure
that when it's trawling or uh scraping
all the websites in the world it doesn't
do too much scraping in mega World it
doesn't do too much scraping in the far
right uh areas now that's what's going
on it's basically they're basically
making sure that that chat GPD doesn't
scrape content that would uh offend work
sensibilities I don't think there's uh
there are imams sitting there at open AI
I think this is just the kind of thing
that's been going on at Google and at
the other uh AI at the other big tech
companies for some time
I think that's concerning
for a couple of reasons
one is that there is a kind of powerful
feedback at work where essentially large
language models are doing an elaborate
form of word prediction on the basis of
a vast sample size of of of phrases and
sentences and of course it starts to
feed off itself because the more the
more content is generated by AI the more
AI generated content the AI has to feed
off
read Hoffman just wrote a book half of
the text is by gpt4
I can anticipate a great flood of AI
generated text in the coming years and
so you get this feedback loop once
you've set these parameters
the flood of new AI generated texts will
ensure that those parameters become
self-reinforcing the second concern is
that if as I suspect it becomes a source
of content for election purposes that is
to save fake content or skewed content
to say nothing of all the Deep fake
videos I think this will have an even
bigger impact than the social media
tools did in in 2016 and in 2020 in 2016
they were kind of left at Trump's
disposal most obviously Facebook ads
were and in 2020 the tech companies did
whatever they could to make it harder
for Trump so I think this is a big deal
I mean the most important democracy in
the world gets to vote every four years
and with every passing iteration of
Technology
there are shifts in the playing field
and level it ain't there's a there's
another thing you you go into a little
bit in in your piece which I think could
have seismic uh impact not just on
society but on Politics as well which is
how it will affect uh the jobs market
and and particularly White Collar jobs
and uh it seems let's say uh you make
the point uh that it's AI can't still
make write a biography about Kissinger
because it can't read all of that you
wrote about it but surely if you scanned
everything that you wrote about
everything that you read to prepare for
the Kissinger book into an AI languaging
model system it could do the work and so
actually
the huge amount of of uh it'll change
the world forever if it can do
everything that historians writers are
doing all analysts everything's just all
white collar work is is over well there
are two things first I mean the case of
of my particular line of work a lot of
important documents are very very hard
to read and uh and for example it would
be very difficult for AI to take on the
Rothschild history that I wrote
20 or so years ago because so much of
the material was in an almost
indecipherable
uden Deutsche German and Hebrew
characters even material relating to the
life of Kissinger is practically
illegible where it's handwritten for
example his parents letters you probably
could get some character recognition
Solutions there but the the key point is
that the access to the materials is
limited AI is learning of off open
source internet content that the problem
for the Chinese companies is there's
much much less of that in Chinese
but the archives that I have been
working on are not open and so the AI
can't access sure but only a few
researchers can so that means I don't
get put out of a job at least in the
remaining years of my life but that's
obviously not of enormous importance to
listeners those of enormous importance
to me Winston
um the the the key reward you respect
the key issues brilliant as you are and
and at this point AI has not quite met
Neil Ferguson's level intelligence but
when we hit the singularity it we will
be at that point and all you have to do
is put it in the right direction then it
will do the work for you well I at times
I wish it were now and then I I could
relax and instead of getting up at four
every morning to write this damn book
but but the key point is that most
predictions about the employment
consequences of new technology are wrong
historically so Sam Alton seven years
ago when I first met him predicted with
absolute confidence that within five
years I.E by 2021 all trucks uh in the
United States would be self-driving and
all the truck drivers would be learning
to code presumably living on the Streets
of San Francisco well I can confirm that
the trucks in the United States are
still driven by people and there are
very few unemployed truck drivers in
fact there's a shortage of truck drivers
so one has to be very careful about
making predictions of large-scale
unemployment the handloom Weavers story
is one that's often been told it was
told by Keynes uh back in in the 1930s
there have been numerous predictions of
mass unemployment through technological
innovations they haven't materialized as
because there are other forms of work
created by the new technologies and
there are a lot of things that AI will
take ages to be able to do I mean maybe
it'll get to be able to drive cars at
some point but well before we get to the
singularity you have to solve a lot of
very complex problems to produce a robot
capable of delivering elderly care or
being an effective primary school
teacher I think we're a long way off
from that and as our society's age more
and more of the workforce will be
engaged in caring for the elderly I
don't think robots are doing that
anytime soon so although it's clear that
a lot of white-collared jobs
particularly low level legal or
accounting jobs are going to be
destroyed that's happening already
because the large language models are
very efficient tools for lawyers dealing
with vast amounts of very boring text
all in an accessible computer readable
form that's happening but I don't think
it means that there'll be like 30
unemployment and truck drivers and legal
clerks roaming the streets starving that
I think is highly unlikely I wondered if
you might indulge me in a bit of I mean
this is perhaps political philosophy
perhaps theology but the
utkowski article that you endorsed says
at one point and I want to read this
because I didn't endorse it I quoted it
then disagreed with it just to be right
okay well so you might disagree with
this then uh yukowski writes I'd be
remiss in my moral duties as a human if
I did not also mention that we have no
idea how to determine whether AI systems
are aware of themselves since we have no
idea how to decode anything that goes on
in the giant inscrutable arrays and
therefore we may at some point
inadvertently create digital Minds which
are truly conscious and ought to have
right rights and shouldn't be owned so
I wondered whether you you know think
that we get to a point where Ai and
computers and robots
ought to have rights it may be
imperative of human beings
well I don't think we get to that point
anytime soon for the reason I I gave you
the robots are a long way off from being
as good at faking Humanity as these
large language models can fake human
text so that that's a distant problem
it's one that science fiction writers
have grappled with you know should the
replicants of Rights that's the central
question of Blade Runner which of course
derives from uh Do Androids Dream of
Electric Sheep
I I think that we have a much more
imminent uh struggle over animal rights
to get through before anybody starts
debating uh AI rights but they're linked
I think because
um so Tom Shivers does this well in his
book the AI aren't don't hate you or
something like that I think it's I think
that's the name of the of the book but a
lot of the the people and I'm sure
you've met these people in California a
lot of the people behind this this the
AI type thing it's it's a rationalist
atheist movement so uh and and this
weird stuff that it's kind of culty that
I've heard and I met some of these
people there's like polyamorous aspects
to it and it's a bit bizarre but but
crucially a lot of them are rationalist
atheists and that this is even a
question see uh that that they might
have rights or that animals might have
rights isn't let's say a question for me
as a Christian like that that in a
metaphysical sense no we we go back to
scription that's not even something we
have to worry about but that's what I
think linked is do animals have rights
do robots have right because it just
goes down to Consciousness and sentience
are we even different to them so uh that
I guess uh where do you stand on that
well I I mean I think we've already uh
accepted that animals have animal rights
Not Human Rights but they have some
rights otherwise we wouldn't have laws
that protect them from from cruelty I
think with uh large language models uh
the question doesn't really arise it'll
arise when there are human-like robots
and then people will start to raise
these questions and they won't be able
to answer them because their brains will
have been entirely wiped clean of
philosophical and ethical content by the
masters of Silicon Valley I think there
is something very suspicious and uh
unnerving about that curious ideological
convergence of uh the the things that
you alluded to in addition we should
mention the Quest for immortality
um
preoccupation of the Lords of the valley
uh the the the the the dangers uh of
this kind of thinking were well
illustrated by the case of Sam bankman
freed the great crypto fraud I think if
you are uh taught these things at a
young age you probably will get
completely decoupled from uh from the
ethics uh of not just of Christianity
but of any major religion
so I find all this repugnant and uh
don't want to live forever have no
desire to become a cyborg and uh
certainly don't intend to uh Grant
rights to uh to human like robots but
as I said part of the point of large
language models is that they will
populate uh the internet with uh AI
generated text which will be very good
at faking Humanity remember the critical
thing about AI is it's not
human it should really be called
non-human intelligence not artificial
intelligence or inhuman intelligence
because we have to remember it's not at
all like our intelligence
it's faking it and what's most alarming
to me is how excitedly Humanity embraced
chat GPT euphorically it was addictive
and what we were really being mesmerized
by was
essentially computer programs pretending
to be human and doing it convincingly
enough for some people at least to be
fooled that's that's disturbing because
the real point about AI is precisely
it's not human it's just pretending to
be human it's real defining
characteristics revealed by the way it
plays chess which is like an alien
playing chess that that should I think
make us aware of the fact that it's an
alien intelligence that's been called
into being here and this much of
yutkovsky's argument I buy that as it
becomes more intelligent than us as its
computational power exceeds our own it
is likely to behave in Alien non-human
ways what we have to worry about is not
replicants
that are indistinguishable almost
indispensable from humans we have to
worry about robots with an entirely
alien intelligence that currently we're
intent on building now that we should
worry about can I just pick you back up
on your point about
um uh
finding it repugnant that the transhuman
stuff and uh because presumably have a
line that Mary Harrington makes an
argument uh that the first human
transhuman technology was the
contraceptive pill uh and so
um maybe you find all that the pill
itself uh repugnant because no no is
where are you on the line then between
here and and living forever that where
do you draw the line of repugnancy oh in
the Soggy Center
okay you know you're not going to get me
to adopt Roman Catholic positions on
contraception in a way no I mean I I
think there's a kind of uh rather good
compromise that has worked uh that has
evolved in uh with respect to birth
control it's constantly going to be
contested but I think we've actually
arrived at uh a modus vivendi if that's
not the inappropriate phrase and we
should be relieved that we've done that
because in a counterfactual world
without birth control I don't think I
don't think we'd be uh we'd be very
pleased at the spectacle now I'll ask
you one last question if I may in your
book civilization you argue that Samuel
Huntington was uh wronged that the
future of uh conflict will be between
civilizations and rather it will be
intra-civilizational and and there's
some reason to see now as geopolitics
are today you might be right although we
might be in a cold war with China so
perhaps he's right but I wondered then
with the Advent of AI how your argument
might have changed if you might revise
that position if the robots are are the
new enemy how does that uh affect your
thought well right now ai is from a
geopolitical point of view a a tool in
the Armory or toolkit of two superpowers
and nobody else because only the United
States and China has companies capable
of uh this kind of innovation and as I
mentioned earlier it's probably best to
think of a cold war framework and to see
this as the latest
feature of the arms race that
characterizes cold Wars
are
I think this the Huntington hypothesis
has been repeatedly falsified if one
looks at the hot Wars of modern times
overwhelmingly the wars that have
happened since Huntington published that
essay have been within civilizations and
take take a look at Ukraine uh I mean I
know there are some differences between
ukrainians and Russians but really the
truth is that this is a war between
two very similar peoples and the
ukrainians are having to kind of learn
Ukrainian to make themselves less
Russian as part of the building of their
Nation the narcissism of small
differences propels much more conflict
than civilizations clash and part of the
point of a cold war is that it's not
really a clash a cold war is a piece
that is no peace that was George
Orwell's term that's what the US and
China currently have and I'll believe
Huntington was right if there's a hot
war between the United States and China
but right now that's not my base case
because that would be so catastrophic
even without artificial intelligence to
help it along great well Neil thank you
so much for speaking with me today
fascinating I'm sure listeners would
have loved that thanks Winston
[Music]
foreign